la semaine dernière j'étais invité à une
table ronde comme intervenante sur le
thème comment le cerveau réagit-il face
aux épreuves
et je devais témoigner aux côtés d'une
femme remarquable qui a traversé
l'atlantique à la rame et qui a failli
mourir parce que sa barque s'est
renversé sur le coup je me suis dit ouh
là il ya un petit problème de casting je
l'air et ont vécu d'extraordinaire
comparé à cette femme je n'ai jamais
survécu aux éléments déchaînés dans des
circonstances terrifiante
je me suis dit peut-être que
l'organisateur crois que je traverse des
choses vraiment horrible et que ma vie
est aussi difficile que traverse l océan
à la rame et bâle va pas être déçu
qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir leur
raconter peut-être qu'il faut que
j'invente des trucs pour avoir l'air
hyper éprouvé en fait les gens pensent
que je suis un bon exemple pour parler
des preuves mais de mon point de vue ce
n'est pas du tout le cas la capacité à
être heureux et le fait d'être
confrontés à des obstacles
ces deux choses qui n'ont rien à voir et
qui n'ont aucun lien de cause à effet je
sais pas si certains d'entre vous ont vu
le film qui est sorti a pas très
longtemps le cinéma celle sur mars
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
d'un point de vue extérieur on se dit où
la seule sur marques la vache j'aimerais
pas être à sa place ça ça doit être une
vraie épreuve
et pourtant quand on côtoie le
personnage de l'intérieur on se rend
compte qu'il n'y a jamais le moindre
moment de panique le moindre moment de
déprime simplement une succession de
petits problèmes à résoudre les uns à la
suite des autres pour finalement réussir
à s'en sortir
en fait ce qu'a vécu cette femme dans
l'eau et en fait c'est ce que je vis moi
aussi au quotidien
confronté à des milliers d'obstacles que
je dois réussir à surmonter pour pouvoir
mener la vie dont j'ai envie
mais en fait ça c'est un peu comme vous
en fait il ya une vraie différence entre
les ternes des preuves et d'obstacles si
on regarde dans le dictionnaire
l'épreuve se définit comme un test par
lequel on mesure la résistance de
quelque chose et l'obstacle se définit
comme ceux qui s'opposent à la marche ce
qui empêche d'avancer
de mon point de vue je suis confronté à
une série de petits obstacles que je
dois réussir à surmonter ce parce que
vous avez mis dans la moquette me et
pourtant vous de votre point de vue vous
dit que ma situation est une épreuve
parce que je dois faire preuve d'une
grande force de résistance pour pas me
laisser abattre
j'aime beaucoup cette définition du mot
obstacles ceux qui s'opposent à la
marche parce que vous vous doutez que
pour moi le terme d'une marche revêt une
signification bien particulière
mon principal obstacle dans la vie c'est
bien évidemment la marche au sens de
mouvement le fait de marcher d'avancé
mais aussi et surtout la marche au sens
architectural du terme
pour moi les marches sont partout et par
marche
je ne parle pas seulement d'escalier je
parle de toutes les petites marches du
quotidien seuils de portes trottoirs
immeuble ou restaurants voiture
transports boutiques bureaux pour vous
ces marches sont invisibles et si je
vous demande combien de marche vous
allez monter depuis ce matin je pense
que vous aurez bien du mal à me répondre
pour moi une marche c'est un obstacle
qui m'ont clou sur le trottoir qui me
laisse à la porte pour vous une marche
c'est un élément qui permette d'entrer
quelque part d'avancées pour moi le fait
d'être incapable de monter une marche ça
équivaut à rester enfermée chez moi pour
vous une marche
c'est un point d'appui pour progresser
mais en fait est ce que nos situations
sont vraiment ces différentes que ça ne
vous pas vous aussi au quotidien
confrontés à des obstacles qui vous
empêchent d'avancer je voudrais qu'on
prenne ce temps pour essayer de voir
s'il n'y a pas un moyen de transformer
ces obstacles en opportunité en fait la
seule différence entre vous et moi c'est
que moi je n'ai pas le choix je suis
obligé de trouver des solutions sans
quoi je resterai immobile comme un arbre
enraciné sans trottoir
du coup je dois en permanence déjouer
les obstacles contourner les systèmes et
ça en fait ce n'est rien de plus que du
hacking les personnes en situation de
handicap sont obligés d'être des supers
à coeur du quotidien apprendre à
utiliser son corps au maximum de ses
capacités
transformer l'environnement anticiper
les situations et les réactions j'ai ici
à mes côtés un très bon exemple mon
chien il n'y a pas un chien aveugle
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
c'est un chien qui a été élevé pendant
deux ans pour apprendre à faire tous les
petits gestes que chez moi je ne peux
pas personne allumer la lumière ouvrir
les portes
ramasser un objet que je fais tomber et
me le déposer sur les genoux
en fait plusieurs fois je me suis
retrouvé tout seul chez moi dans le noir
parce que la nuit était tombée trop tôt
et que je pouvais pas appuyer sur
l'interrupteur et je pouvais pas non
plus appeler à l'aide parce que mon
téléphone portable était tombé par terre
et donc je ne pouvais pas le ramasser
du coup je me suis dit qu'il fallait que
je
une solution qui me permettrait d'être
le plus autonome possible india c'est
typiquement le genre de solution qu'on
est capable de développer quand on
connaît par coeur les obstacles
le problème est qu'on sait exactement où
on veut aller en fait maintenant qu'on a
identifié où sont les marches il ya qu
une seule différence
ça se joue entre les gens qui restent
sur le trottoir en bas de la marche et
les gens qui parviennent à surmonter les
obstacles et ça ça se joue en quatre
points essentiels le premier l'éducation
le second l'acceptation le troisième
point la révolte
la quatrième point la volonté de créer
l'éducation c'est probablement le plus
important de ces quatre points
parce que c'est ça qui va déterminer la
façon dont on se considère comme
individu par rapport aux autres mais
aussi par rapport au monde dans la
grande chance c'est d'avoir été élevé
dans un environnement 100% valide
entouré d'enfants tout à fait normaux
comme tous les enfants de mon âge
d'avoir été traité par les parents
exactement comme les autres princes
du coup je n'ai jamais subi cette
différence que peut être vous vous
ressentez je me voyais exactement comme
les aux enfants de mon âge
d'importantes plein d'énergie avec une
envie de faire plein de choses
du coup créé mon entreprise pour moi
c'était normal parce que c'était normal
dans mon contexte une entreprise étant
par essence une solution à un obstacle
mais évidemment il ya des situations
auxquelles je suis confronté au
quotidien contre lesquels je ne peux
rien contre lesquels je ne pourrai
jamais rien je ne pourrai jamais marché
je ne pourrais jamais faire de telles
choses que j'aurais aimé faire
l'acceptation
c'est l'étape la plus importante parce
que en fait c'est la plus savoureuse la
plus libératrice
c'est ça qui permet d économiser de
l'énergie
j'aurais préféré marcher c'est sûr mais
à quoi bon préféré à quoi bon se
lamenter ma situation est comme aller
donc autant faire avec
et quitte à faire avec autant faire au
mieux l'acceptation c'est vraiment ce
qui permet de transformer l'énergie
qu'on aurait pu consacrer à des petites
choses et de la consacrer à des choses
qui permettent d'avancer de progresser
mais quand on veut surmonter un obstacle
on est forcément confronté à un moment
de révolte je vous parle pas de révolte
revendicative descendre dans la rue
crier ça c'est pas mon truc je vous
parle de révolte créatrice quand on est
une marre de me retrouver à la porte de
tous les restaurants auquel je voulais
aller avec mes amis parce qu'il y avait
une marche et que je pouvais pas rentrer
je me suis dit bon ok je vais faire des
petits trempé je les aurai toujours avec
moi quand on est une marre de me
retrouver seul dans le noir parce que je
pouvais pas allumer la lumière
je me suis dit ok je vais chercher une
solution qui me permettent d'être tous
nous quand j'en ai eu marre ne pas
pouvoir me déplacer librement d'aller où
je voulais quand je voulais j'ai décidé
de quitter mon job est de créer mon
entreprise pour pouvoir faciliter mes
propres déplacements mais aussi ceux de
toutes les personnes qui sont dans la
même situation que moi on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi-même en
entrepreneuriat on dit qu'il faut
toujours répondre à un besoin
mais quel besoin connaissons mieux que
ses propres besoins
il ya une très jolie phrase d'albert
camus qui dit ce qu'il y à de nobles
dans la révolte ce n'est pas la révolte
en elle même mais c'est ce qu'elle exige
ce qu'il ya de nobles en fait c'est
notre capacité à créer dépasser les
obstacles et les surmonter si je suis
ici devant vous ce soir c'est pas pour
que vous m'applaudissent y est pour ma
résistance aux épreuves que vous
imaginez avoir été les miennes mais pour
que vous preniez conscience démarche vos
propres marche invisible peut-être mais
qui sont devant vous
pour faire naître votre propre révolte
et encourager votre volonté de créer
merci